[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight if there's one lesson of
this weekend's march for our lives
it's that ending violence in America is
easy so easy that even children know how
to do it all that stands between the
broken the chaotic country we live in
and the peaceful utopia of the future
it's a very small group of very evil
people mostly Republicans as parkland
student David hog noted the other day
there are some quote sick effers out
there who want to sell more guns murder
more children and honestly just get
reelected well in the stage on Saturday
his classmate Alex wind agreed with this
quote if you take money from the NRA
when told the crowd you have chosen
death so it's all pretty straightforward
if the NRA wasn't so blindly committed
to killing children if they didn't enjoy
murder for its own sake we wouldn't have
school shootings in the first place it's
that simple
speaker's of the March told us that
repeatedly in the media dutifully
amplified that message and formed a
protective ring around the activists as
political reporter Ben white put it
quote the sickening efforts to slime
undermine defame and dehumanize these
young people betrays an enormous amount
of fear in other words
shut up America don't ask questions the
kids know what they're doing but do they
know what they're doing this weekend
voxcom ran a story with this title I've
covered gun violence for years the
solutions aren't a big mystery the piece
was written by someone called German
Lopez whom fox.com
identified as quote a senior reporter
Lopez graduated with a journalism degree
from the University of Cincinnati in
2012 he's still in his 20s I've covered
gun violence for years maybe an
overstatement nevertheless Lopez
approached this subject with all the
self confidence of an eminent research
scientist wading in data what America
likely needs Lopez concluded is
something more like Australia's
mandatory buyback program essentially a
gun confiscation scheme paired with this
serious ban on specific firearms
potentially including all semi-automatic
weapon
all semi-automatic weapons mmm there are
more than a hundred million of those in
the United States right now and the
overwhelming majority of them are
sitting in the bedroom closets of
law-abiding Americans who've done
nothing wrong and don't have plans to do
anything wrong so how exactly would we
confiscate all those guns somebody would
have to go door-to-door to take them by
force arresting anyone who resists in
the name of ending gun violence people
would be shot to death there's no
question about that so who exactly is
gonna do it local police the FBI Delta
Force German lopes the Vox did not
volunteer for that job himself instead
he blamed the NRA for blocking the whole
idea quote the Supreme Court and US
lawmakers backed by the powerful gun
lobby particularly the NRA widely agree
that the Second Amendment does put
barriers on how far restrictions can go
hmm wait we've got news here the Supreme
Court
according to Vox is also in the pocket
of the NRA is there evidence of that
which justices are taking gun money
exactly
whereas Vox just throwing out that claim
because all decent people who live in
big cities already know the NRA is evil
so why get hung up on details this is
the problem with letting children write
news stories the articles tend to be
dumb and intentionally or not they tend
to be inaccurate and dishonest worst of
all they tend to reinforce the fantasy
that complex problems have simple
solutions because that's what most
children believe in real life nothing is
simple we don't really know why the
incidents of school shootings has arisen
even as the proportion of households
with firearms has dropped we ought to do
our best to find out the self righteous
kids screaming at you on television over
the weekend aren't helping at all Erica
Thomas is the Georgia state
representative and an advocate of gun
control and she joins us tonight
representative Thomas thanks are coming
on thanks for having me take her so what
do you think would happen if we tried to
confiscate so-called assault weapons
from law-abiding Americans how would
people respond well I think his yes it's
about how people will respond but let's
look at what happened back in 1994 when
we had a ban on assault rifles when
shootings went down by 43% that is what
we want to happen we want mass shootings
to go down and I think that's the most
important point in this matter but
didn't Columbine take place during the
assault weapons ban and didn't the
overall death by gun the homicide rate
with firearms remain unchanged oh no I
mean I you're right you're totally right
about the Columbine situation but you
know what 43% does not account for all I
said 43% went down just as a factual
matter the the Clinton Justice
Department was required by the law to
study its effects and so we have a
conclusive answer to this question and
the the death rate by firearms did not
decline over that 10-year period so
statistically no lives were saved I mean
that's the conclusion of the DOJ doesn't
that give you pause
no it doesn't give me pause when I think
about in 2004 when Congress lifted that
ban and mass shootings went up by over
200 percent so those are the numbers
we're talking about the numbers those
are the numbers mass shootings went up
so yeah you you might be right about
numbers but I'm going to talk about
numbers it went up those are the numbers
yeah then but the murder rate didn't
didn't move it all but what do you think
would hit so okay those are the numbers
what do you think would happen if law
enforcement pushed by Democratic
politicians tried to take the guns from
law-abiding Americans what do you think
the effect would be well you know I'm
not talking about taking guns from
law-abiding citizens I'm talking about a
ban on assault rifles we are not trying
to promote a militia what war are we
going at that we need assault rifles I
mean I don't you know I don't want to
argue with you but here's the
legislation that you supported in
Georgia
the last assault weapons ban Democrats
in your state push and I'm quoting from
the legislation right here the Georgia
Bureau of Investigations shall cease and
take position possession of any assault
weapon large capacity magazine
armor-piercing bullet or incendiary 50
caliber bullet shall cease and take
possession of that's not voluntary
that's mandatory so you've got hundreds
of thousands of people in your state who
own weapons you say or assault weapons
are you worried that someone might get
killed if law enforcement comes you've
done nothing wrong and so we're taking
your gun away whether you like it or not
what do you think would happen I mean
it's worth thinking that through since
you're supporting a law that would call
for it don't you think you know what I'm
worried about is when the Constitution
was made and when the Second Amendment
was made it stated that of course the
second or Second Amendment but let's
talk about when it was made
that was when assault rifles you had to
take several minutes to reload an
assault rifle and it's to several
seconds so that's three use that
knowledge is very different but let's
review that login okay but you keep
dodging my question and most people do
but I think it's important because we're
getting to a point where actual
legislation has been sponsored and will
be again saying that the government
needs to take people's weapons by force
and if you really care about preventing
deaths I wonder if you're concerned even
a little bit that there might be a
violent reaction to that is that a crazy
thing to suggest you know you know what
it's not a crazy thing sucker you're
totally correct by force is not what we
want to do live in Georgia and in
Georgia we are a red state I'm not about
taking anybody's anything by force I'm
not gonna about then why did you support
a law that says that the state shall
seize and take possession of these guns
what I support is saving lives and what
saving lives is is ban on assault rifles
these kids are out here and they are
stating that we need to put a ban on
assault rifle okay I understand I think
I think we both agree
we're both against killing of course I
just have real concerns about the effect
of the law that you support it but you
don't want to address those let me ask
you this question then the overwhelming
majority of gun deaths in this country
are caused by handguns not by so-called
assault rifles it's a tiny percentage so
why are we banning the gun that causes a
small percentage of killings but leaving
the guns that cause the majority legal
why does that make you may and I
understand what you're saying you may
say that it's a small percentage but
it's your brother or when it's your
sister
she assaulted by assault rifle it's not
a small percentage but whatever you
would have brothers and sisters have
assault rifle it was not a small
percentage of what it comes to you know
don't don't don't demagogue it with me
down playing this hold on I'm not
downplaying the significance of anyone's
death of course I'm as concerned as you
are I'm just wondering why since assault
rifles relatively speaking cause few
deaths handguns cause the overwhelming
majority of deaths why are you not
calling for banning handguns and seizing
and taking possession of handguns I I
don't know why if you care so much about
gun violence
but I would ask you the same question
would you offer us a ban on handguns no
you wouldn't
so that's not the question Michael's
people have a gun as a tool fewer
American households have guns than they
did 40 years ago and yet it's a wife
it's gonna ban on assault rifles that's
the question why not well because you
have over a hundred million
semi-automatic weapons in the United
States right now what do you do with
those do you know people using if people
want to have assault rifles
join the military the military juncture
you wanna join the military in our
country not to shoot our kids in America
that is what is happening that is what
happened if I may ask you a question you
can get